- Docteur Briand, bonsoir,
bienvenue à Découverte en
direct. Nous sommes très heureux
de vous recevoir, parce qu'on
veut connaître, au fond,
le passage, s'il y en a un,
de la pandémie à l'endémie?
Quels sont les scénarios quevou?
Dre SYLVIE BRIAND, ,Organisation
mondiale de la Santé
- Alors, en fait, c'est toujours
très compliqué parce que c'est
difficile de prévoir le futur,
mais en se basant sur les
expériences qu'on a sur d'autres
virus, il y a schématiquement
trois scénarios possibles.
Le premier, le plus favorable,
c'est qu'effectivement, ce virus
devienne en quelque sorte
un virus endémique, comme
les quatre autres coronavirus
endémiques que l'on connaît,
qui va provoquer effectivement
une maladie bénigndie bénigndiei
va circuler rapidement
dans la population.
Le deuxième scénario,
utôt un scénario
qui ressemblerait à la grippe,
et la grippe saisonnière,
us le savez, donc, on a
des épidémies et dans ces
épidémies, il y a des gens qui,
malheureusement, sont à risque
des formes graves
de la maladie et d'en mourir.
Chaque année, avec la grippe,
on a entre 450 000 et 650 000
personnes meurent chaque année
de la grippe, donc ça demande
quand même un programme de lutte
assez bien organisé.
Et le troisième scénario,
qui est un peu le scénario
catastrophe, c'est-à-dire
qu'on va avoir d'autres vari
qui vont émerger, qui seront
différents des variants qu'on
connaît, et donc, ça va demander
mette en cause
les outils qu'on a déjà,
c'est-à-dire qu'on revoit un peu
les vaccins, les traitements,
c ça, c'est le scénario
catastrophe. On l'espère
absolument pas, évidemment,
mais il faut quand même toujour.
Et le premier scénario, c'est
le plus favorable aussi, mais
malheureusement, on ne sait paÇt
prendre quand même plusieurs
variantes pour en arriver là.
- Évidemment, la science a fait
des progrès extraordinaires
depuis deux ans. On nous dit
beaucoup, justement, que la
vaccination a sauvé peut-être
même des millions de personnes.
Il reste qu'on assiste encore
à une course au vaccin.
Cette course au vaccin,
l'OMS a un regard particulier.
Vous faites un appel aux
scientifiques pour peut-être
orienter cette course-là.
De quoi a-t-on besoin justement
pour nous aider, justement, dans
ce scénario catastrophe auquel
on peut s'attendre, mais qu'on
espère qu'il n'arrivera pas?
- Oui, la course au vaccin,
en fait, elle a deux visages.
Le premier visage, c'est la
lutte contre les inéquité et
s'assurer que tout le monde ait
accès au vaccin, tous ceux qui
en ont besoin. Et la deuxième
course, effectivement, c'est
essayer d'avoir des meilleurs
vaccins, soit des vaccins qui,
justement, aient une plus grande
efficacité en utilisant
les plateformes qu'on a déjà
et qui sont déjà utilisées,
en particulier, par exemple
en adaptant la composition
du vaccin aux variants qui
circulent. Mais aussi, l'autre
espoir qu'on a, c'est peut-être
avoir un vaccin qui soit
beaucoup plus efficace sur
la transmission de la maladie.
Pour l'instant, on a des vac
qui sont très bons pour prévenir
les maladies graves et protéger
les gens, les empêcher d'être
hospitalisés et de
mais on voit bien que les
vaccins qu'on a actuellement
ne sont pas aussi efficaces
que l'on aimerait
transmission, puisqu'on a encore
beaucoup de cas, spécialement
avec Omicron.
- En même temps,
évoqué l'iniquité vaccinale.
On apprend aussi par l'OMS
que des millions et des millions
de doses
littéralement, parce que...
par la crainte, en raison de la
crainte qu'elles soient périmées
dans cer..........
On en est où sur cette équité
ou iniquité vaccinale?
- Disons qu'il y a eu beaucoup
puisque le
COVAX annonce qu'ils ont réussi
à distribuer pratiquement
un milliard de doses dans
en dévelo en dévelo en dévelo .
Donc, je pense que l'inéquité
est en train de se combler,omblt
d'équité, mais c'est vrai que
c'est tard. Et puis, il fautr aa
livraison de ces vaccins, parce
qu'effectivement, bon, parfois s
utiliser tous les vaccins qui
ont été livrés pour diversesrais
logistiques, des raisons
matérielles, des raisons quisone
des systèmes de santé dans
ces pays et aussi le faitqu'il e
dans le secteur des soins
qui fait que l'on ne peut pasnéi
vite qu'on voudrait toute
la population, donc il faut
tenir compte aussi de tous
ces empêchements qui sont liés à
la pandémie, liés à des déficits
structurels aussi dans certains
pays et donc faire avec tout ça
pour essayer de s'améliorer.
- Mais je crois qu'il y a une
chose qui est certaine dans
l'esprit des spécialistes de
l'OMS et vous, docteur Briand,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas contrer
cette pandémie avec des doses
de rappel. Nous, ici, on en est
à la troisième. Certaines
villes, une ville au Canada
en est à la 4e dose. Est-ce
qu'on aura une cinquième,
une sixième dose? Ce n'est pas
la voie à suivre, selon vous?
- Non, non, tout à fait, parce
que d'abord, c'est très coûteux
et puis c'est embêtant et en
plus, on a... on ne comprend pas
très bien non plus les effets
ses
répétées de vaccins. Donc,
on pense que c'est beaucoup
r plutôt r plutôt r plutôt r plr
le produit, le vaccin lui-même,
et voir comment on pourra
it, pour que
justement, l'immunité conférée
par la vaccination dure plus nos
permettre d'éviter toutes
les formes de la maladie, pas
seulement les formes graves.miné
les trois scénarios, mais
évidemment, on espère le
premier. On pourrait vivre
le troisième. Quand et avec
quel signal pourrons-nous dire,
conclure, on est passé
de la pandémie à l'endémie?
Et quel est le plus grand
progrès que vous espérez p
la science pour mettre fin
à cette pandémie?
- Alors, c'est difficile
de donner des dates, etc., parce
que, comme vous av
le virus s'adapte.
Nous aussi on s'adapte, donc
c'est un petit peu comme un
marathon, en fait. Je pense
qu'on est certainement dans
les derniers kilomètres de
ce marathon, mais je ne sais pas
encore. Je ne vois pas encore
la ligne d'arrivée. Ça, c'est
clair. Ce qui est sûr, c'est qur
lutter contre la pandémie,
on a de plus en plus d'outils.
On a tous ces vaccins.
Il y en
sont à l'état de phase pré-mise
sur le marché, en tous les cas,
et on va certainement dans les
mois à venir aussi avoir plus de
vaccins,...............
Donc, je crois qu'on est
vraiment sur la pente favorable,
mais très difficile de prévoir.
Donc, je pense que les progrès
pour la science, ce qu'on
espère, c'est vraiment justement
qu'on ait des meilleurs vaccins,
que ce soit avec les plateformes
actuelles ou d'autres
plateformes qui pourraient
arriver dans le futur.
Des meilleurs traitements aussi,
qu'on en ait plus à tous
les stades de la maladie
et on aimerait aussi avoir
des tests qui puissent servir
dans différentes circonstances,
notamment des tests rapides qui
soient beaucoup plus fiables.
Comme ça, on pourrait ajouter à
notre boite à outils et faire en
sorte que même si cette ma
reste encore une maladie grave,
qui malheureusement tue encore
des gens, on pourrait apprendre,
dans notre monde du 21e siè
à vivre de mieux en mieux avec
et justement réduire son impact
non seulement sur la santé,
mais aussi sur nos sociétés
et nos économies.
- Alors je retiens qu'on doit
rester très prudent. On doit
rester quand même optimiste
et en ce sens, garder espoir
pour cette année 2022.
Docteure Briand, merci beaucoup.
- Tout à fait, merci beaucoup.
- Au rev